what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today thank you
for clicking on this video so we are
going to talk about some dc news that's
been heavily reported to be coming out
of comic-con tomorrow i'm going to be
having a marvel video going up on the
channel i asked on our community page
and twitter what are you most hoping
comes out of comic con so i'm going to
be reacting to and riffing off of those
responses but right now i want to talk
about this which kind of threw me for a
loop because earlier this week you might
have heard there was this rolling stones
article that came out about the wb
claims involving a bot infested snyder
cut movement that was basically saying
13 of hashtag released the snyder cut
movement accounts were bots takeaway
that seemed pretty obvious that they
wanted the readers to have was wb they
got duped they got duped by a bunch of
you know this vocal minority that was
just so passionate that created all
these bots and then they wasted all this
money now i'm probably gonna circle back
to that in a minute but this is the
video is not mainly about that but the
reason i'm bringing it up is because of
what's being reported on right now is
something that i very much do associate
with you know the snyder verse when i
woke up i saw this all over my twitter
feed it's been up for a few hours now
henry cavill's superman return is
rumored for an official announcement by
henry cavill at hall h
this weekend and honestly i'll tell you
guys
when i first read that
the way it was presented
my heart stopped for a couple of beats
i know that sounds like silly and
dramatic i just was like wow wait
is this actually happening there's a
level with you unlike superman i
actually lost hope that this would ever
happen so diving into it more websites i
mainly been pulling from this deadline
article and deadline is obviously one of
the more reliable entertainment news
outlets the article goes on to say
dwayne johnson in the warner brothers
theatrical session will serve as
marvel's opening act earlier in the day
with black adam and shazam fury of the
gods getting their much-deserved
close-ups on the hall h stage there's
also a buzz that henry cavill put in a
surprise appearance to talk up more
superman there's just been so many
conflicting reports about henry cavill's
superman future for years now many have
stated he's gone others have stated he's
in negotiations for like a future cameos
reportedly the new people in charge of
warner media are like no we need to
revitalize superman regardless even if
you take henry cavill out of the
equation it's very obvious that they
just haven't had a clear confident
direction of what to do with superman
the last two appearances if i'm not
mistaken other than you know zack
snyder's justice league which is meant
to predate these is shazam and
peacemaker with which both featured
faceless voiceless cameos by the man of
steel it's just kind of crazy to know
that even with his time as superman he
did have a you know a complete character
arc from man of steel to zack snyder's
justice league he's only had one solo
outing as superman now one thing that's
really kind of kept hope alive is online
teases that dwayne johnson and henry
cavill have given about them mashing up
together because dwayne johnson he's
been very outspoken about wanting black
adam to fight superman i mean dwayne the
rock johnson he obviously holds a lot of
power and influence and is also very
much about staying connected to what the
fans want although i'm sure if he fought
superman he'd probably make sure that
superman lost her that'd be a draw or
some [ __ ] like that so if this
report is true i'm totally cool with
there being more cameo appearances as a
way to you know get him back into the
freaking dc films god damn i really
think he deserves another solo movie
fans have wanted another man of steel
follow-up for so long and like i said
earlier i really appreciated his arc
through the three films that he was in
even though zack snyder had a plan for
two more justice league films i still
feel like the way that film ended
whether you go off of the joss whedon
version or the zack snyder's justice
league version you can still do another
solo outing another official sequel to
man of steel and my god i hope that if
they were to do that that it would be
following after the events attack
centers justice league another job
sweden despite whichever one they would
want to make it a sequel out of you can
still just make it your own and just
factor in the events of the prior
installments they could do it in a way
where it's like oh it could be followed
after either one of those depending on
how you interpret it now for me the real
question is if there was to be another
solo outing would zack snyder return to
direct it that just seems
very unlikely because of the major
contention that's very public between
zack snyder and wb it's not impossible
it's not possible but that is one that
make me go wow holy [ __ ] they squashed
some real beefs there but i'll be honest
you know i could see another director
doing it but whoever they would get for
it i i think they would have to be able
to match or level up from the man of
steel action out of the zack snyder
trilogy the man of steel action is still
the best superman action has ever been
and i'll be damned if we get another
solo movie and the action is nowhere
near on that level they don't have to
like destroy cities and [ __ ] but you
know like the choreography and like the
fighting style it was just so great
although i am curious from snyder fans
would you be cool with henry returning
for a solo movie without zack stein it's
a big part of what i feel like ignited
the snyder cut movement was more than
just i want to see a better film was
being aware of the treatment and
handling of zack snyder while dealing
with a personal tragedy so getting a bad
film compounded with that usually
ignites a passion like nothing ignites a
passion more than feeling like
something's been wronged and we gotta
fight for justice all puns intended
because a lot of that rolling stone
article like i get it there's obviously
a lot of passionate fans out there who
can be very difficult to deal with who
can be very hostile and insulting to
others every fandom has this level of
aggressiveness and bullying and there's
many who believe that the snyder cut fan
base had the worst of them i understand
but when we're talking about this bot
situation you know i'm going back to
like the if we look back at the launch
of hbo max one of the main things to
truly entice people to sign up very
early on was green lighting zack
snyder's justice league you know while
13 of the accounts are fake 87 percent
is very real you're still telling me 87
is very real and that 80
that's a lot of people i don't know the
exact number but it's
it's got to be a lot and regardless it's
also saying the movement is mainly real
people this whole narrative about we got
duped and bullied into releasing this by
a small amount of loud angry fans to me
it just didn't register as the data
doesn't support this that 87 percent of
people can be a lot of people like think
of it like this this might be a terrible
example but let me let me try to think
of it if i go and rhyme tomatoes and i
see a movie has a 70 score and then i
see another movie that has a 90 score
it's easy to look at that and go one
movie is definitely better if i see that
70 score movie has like 350 reviews and
the 90 score movie has like
20 reviews it kind of changes up the
variables you know like how many people
make up that 87 percent i i definitely
could use a better analogy than the
right tomatoes we just talked about for
so many years and as one of the channels
i was also covering it i don't know it
seemed very real to me and the last time
we saw henry cavill superman was in that
film and his superman is very much
associated with the snyder verse so to
me it'd just be kind of crazy in the
week of wb again trying to take down
snyder that this announcement would
happen even without zack snyder's theory
in the future of superman now i know
that marvel has a reputation for being
you know other than the leaks for being
very successful at keeping their
announcements for comic-con very
secretive i don't know if warner
brothers is as good about it and you
know i i definitely do believe that
henry cavill can't continue on without
zack snyder directing regardless that's
just my two cents on this uh i'm hoping
that this really does get announced that
would be very exciting and i'll just
quickly say despite it being several
years since henry cavill played the man
of steel obviously he can still pull off
superman
he can still pull it off yeah leave me
your thoughts down below thank you guys
for being here you can subscribe click
that bell keep a lookout for whatever we
come cover at comic-con catch you guys
soon